[Music]
there are little girls who dream of being a
dancer being a doctor being an
astronaut miss universe space
angel sometimes
when I was little my dream was to be me
and I dreamed of being a woman
[Music]
my name is angel a ponce I'm a model
professionally my first contact
with beauty pageants came through
fashion at work i was with colleagues
who were commenting that they were going to
appear at a casting to
represent the city in the miss world
spain contest so i
applied in 2018 cannell  the crown of miss
universe spain and that led me to
represent my country miss universe and
there you can be honored for having
made history as the first
trans woman to participate in a
miss universe beauty pageant
the fact of being the first fact that took
me  All the credit, all the applause,
but I have also had to live through a lot of
vulgarity, you come across many stones
along the way in my case for being trans,
but then I also know  the
difficult position trend one because well, he
doesn't fit the profile others because of the
simple fact of being who he was and being the way he
was also because they fire you, you know
then you have to be very strong to
bear that
[Music]
and
when you are the image
Representing your country in
any field is already a
responsibility, but in my case even more so
because it not only represented the
flag of my country, it represented the
flag of diversity and also the
flag of human rights,
regardless of their identity or
race.  of their sex of any difference
all of us at some point in our lives
have faced prejudice we
have felt less we have had
doubts we have been rejected but I believe that if
there is a mirror in which anyone has been able to
look
[Music]
me  I have always thought that the problem
is not being a trans woman the problem is being
born in a world that is not prepared
for trans people the world must  to
go forward and that we do not have to
take steps back, what I do know is that I am going
to continue training to be the best
version of myself regardless of
where I am from, continue to be a voice and
continue to be a visible face and
activist for the rights of the collective
lgbt
[Music]